Now that we have identified
a set of risk factors,
let's use this data to predict
the 10 year risk of CHD.
First, we'll randomly
split our patients
into a training set
and a testing set.
Then, we'll use
logistic regression
to predict whether or not
a patient experienced CHD
within 10 years of
the first examination.
Keep in mind that all
of the risk factors
were collected at the first
examination of the patients.
After building our model, we'll
evaluate the predictive power
of the model on the test set.
Let's go to R and create our
logistic regression model.
In our R console, we'll
call our data set framingham
and use the read.csv function
to read in the data file
"framingham.csv".
Remember to navigate to
the directory containing
the file "framingham.csv"
before reading in the data.
Let's take a look at our data
by using the str function.
We have data for 4,240
patients and 16 variables.
We have the demographic
risk factors male, age,
and education; the
behavioral risk
factors currentSmoker
and cigsPerDay;
the medical history risk
factors BPMeds, prevalentStroke,
prevalentHyp, and diabetes;
and the physical exam risk
factors totChol, sysBP, diaBP,
BMI, heartRate, and glucose
level.
The last variable is the
outcome or dependent variable,
whether or not the
patient developed
CHD in the next 10 years.
Now let's split our data into a
training set and a testing set
using sample.split like we
did in the previous lecture.
We first need to load
the library caTools.
Now, let's set our seed
and create our split.
We'll start by setting
our seed to 1000,
and then use the sample.split
function to create the split.
The first argument is
the outcome variable
framingham$TenYearCHD.
And the second argument
is the percentage of data
that we want in the training
set or the SplitRatio.
Here, we'll put 65% of the
data in the training set.
When you have more
data like we do here,
you can afford to put less
data in the training set
and more in the testing set.
This will increase
our confidence
in the ability of the
model to extend to new data
since we have a larger
test set, and still
give us enough data
in the training set
to create our model.
You typically want to put
somewhere between 50% and 80%
of the data in the training set.
Now, let's split up
our data using subset.
We'll call our
training set "train"
and use the subset function
to take a subset of framingham
and take the observations for
which split is equal to TRUE.
We'll call our
testing set "test"
and again use the
subset function
to take a subset of
framingham and take
the observations for
which split equals FALSE.
Now we're ready to build
our logistic regression
model using the training set.
Let's call it framinghamLog,
and we'll use the glm function
like we did in the
previous lecture
to create a logistic
regression model.
We'll use a nice
little trick here
where we predict our
dependent variable
using all of the other
variables in the data set
as independent variables.
First, type the name of
the dependent variable,
TenYearCHD, followed by the
tilde and then a period.
This will use all of
the other variables
in the data set as
independent variables
and is used in
place of listing out
all of the independent
variables' names separated
by the plus sign.
Be careful doing
this with data sets
that have identifying
variables like a patient ID
or name since you
wouldn't want to use
these as independent variables.
Following the period, we
need to give the argument
that defines the data
set to use, data = train.
And then, the final argument
for a logistic regression model
is family = binomial.
Let's take a look at the
summary of our model.
It looks like male,
age, prevalent stroke,
total cholesterol, systolic
blood pressure, and glucose
are all significant
in our model.
Cigarettes per day and
prevalent hypertension
are almost significant.
All of significant variables
have positive coefficients,
meaning that higher
values in these variables
contribute to a
higher probability
of 10-year coronary
heart disease.
Now, let's use this
model to make predictions
on our test set.
We'll call our
predictions predictTest
and use the predict
function, which
takes as arguments the name
of our model, framinghamLog,
then type = "response",
which gives us probabilities,
and lastly newdata = test,
the name of our testing set.
Now, let's use a
threshold value of 0.5
to create a confusion matrix.
We'll use the table function
and give as the first argument,
the actual values,
test$TenYearCHD,
and then as the second
argument our predictions,
predictTest > 0.5.
With a threshold of 0.5,
we predict an outcome of 1,
the true column, very rarely.
This means that our model
rarely predicts a 10-year CHD
risk above 50%.
What is the accuracy
of this model?
Well, it's the sum of the cases
we get right, 1069 plus 11,
divided by the total number
of observations in our data
set, 1069 + 6 + 187 + 11.
So the accuracy of our
model is about 84.8%.
We need to compare this to the
accuracy of a simple baseline
method.
The more frequent outcome
in this case is 0,
so the baseline method would
always predict 0 or no CHD.
This baseline method would
get an accuracy of 1069
+ 6-- this is the total number
of true negative cases--
divided by the total number
of observations in our data
set, 1069 + 6 + 187 + 11.
So the baseline model would
get an accuracy of about 84.4%.
So our model barely beats the
baseline in terms of accuracy.
But do we still have a valuable
model by varying the threshold?
Let's compute the
out-of-sample AUC.
To do this, we first need
to load the ROCR package.
And then, we'll use
the prediction function
of the ROCR package to
make our predictions.
Let's call the output of that
ROCRpred and use the prediction
function, which takes as a
first argument our predictions,
predictTest, and then as
a second argument the true
outcome, test$TenYearCHD.
Then, we need to type
as.numeric(performance(ROCRpred,
"auc")@y.values).
This will give us the AUC
value on our testing set.
So we have an AUC of
about 74% on our test set,
which means that the model can
differentiate between low risk
patients and high risk
patients pretty well.
As we saw in R, we were able
to build a logistic regression
model with a few
interesting properties.
It rarely predicted
10-year CHD risk above 50%.
So the accuracy of the model
was very close to the baseline
model.
However, the model could
differentiate between low risk
patients and high risk
patients pretty well
with an out-of-sample
AUC of 0.74.
Additionally, some of
the significant variables
suggest possible
interventions to prevent CHD.
We saw that more cigarettes per
day, higher cholesterol, higher
systolic blood pressure,
and higher glucose levels
all increased risk.
Later in the lecture,
we'll discuss
some medical interventions
that are currently
used to prevent CHD.